welcome to this video a new part of the
opening disaster series yeah the sir a
game show near was played between
Stefano Tata and Viktor Korchnoi yeah
time time at the time I'm talking about
1978 at the time was I'm not sure if it
wasn't the number one Italian player
probably probably he was at the time
Italian chess was not as strong as it is
today were led by Fabiano Kawana but
they also have some other strong
grandmasters yeah well Tata here was
playing right against Korchnoi at the
time 1978 the Challenger to come up off
the corner was definitely world number
two at the time and very serious
challenger to Karpov he almost won the
match in 1978 was very very close yeah
let's look at this game
Tata played one four and coach no I
played the French the French at the time
was coach noise main defense he for
instance had played it tons of times in
his 1974 match against Karpov
this was the candidates final that was
deciding who should challenge challenge
Fischer in 75 so Korchnoi had had this
shot at the title
in 74 already if he would have beaten
Karpov he would have been the challenger
to Fischer and maybe become world
champion official wouldn't have played
yeah a cautionary played the French lot
d at the time with great success he
didn't play it in the 1978 match though
for some reason not sure why exactly had
good results okay and let's then look at
this
Tata played the exchange variation
somewhat dreaded line for black players
it's a little bit it's a little bit
boring it's nothing challenging but it
it does not get you to the kind of
complex structures that black players
normally want however if you are black
and your opponent display
that you shouldn't despair very often
people playing the exchanges why have a
very very narrow-minded yeah idea they
just want to draw and it is your task as
black to try to unbalance the game a bit
and very often you succeed and can still
win yeah in this game we see a nice way
for black to do that um and this is
against the mood before Bishop b3 white
here has sir has mainly three moves
Bishop b3 Knight f3 and c4 the main
choice nowadays as I guess in idea three
it's the most flexible move it still
keeps the option of playing c4 but it
still avoids what happens in this game
here Bishop d3 has some slight drawback
or even two drawbacks
Knight f3 and white can also play a C
form instead if you want a more more
fighting game this is quite interesting
in fact
yeah well Bishop d3 and now black has
two choices that are less interesting
against Knight f3 or even incorrect
black can play knight c6 which forces
some sort of concession but for white
something like this for example when you
get up in early very nice or c3 after
you have forced him to place his three
and now you have various ideas one is to
play a setup like this
with Bishop f5 to come the second way to
try to punish we should be three and in
fact is's what I would recommend black
players to do it's what corner played he
played c5 Korchnoi was very m was very
enthusiastic about this movement I
remember that he did he made it he made
columns on this game for for the chess
informant for other publications where
he gave Bishop d3 mmm questionable move
c5 exclamation mark there is some truth
to that black am probably shouldn't be
better this is
an exaggeration but it's a there is some
point to this move the idea is that if
you get to an isolated Queen power
position like after the capture here the
white bishop on d3 is not ideally placed
it is not a terrible spot for the bishop
but normally in iqp positions you rather
have it on a tool to increase your
control over deform and it's sometimes a
bit misplaced on d3 also considering
that after night a three days possibly
Bishop deform it is nothing terrible but
something that black players yeah
certainly shouldn't shy away from also
it leads to an unbalance of the position
so c5 is interesting when I got this as
black I almost play almost all the time
played c5 and I got good good results
with that yeah Tata I played Knight f3
and commotion I went 96 yeah black also
could consider to play c4 and gain a
tempo but this would ya take some
dynamism away from the structure so
probably not as good yeah 96 a good move
yeah in term I think now white should
probably just castle or play c3 tot I
played Queenie to check and I think this
is the first of a series of slightly
doubtful moves and series of slightly
inaccurate moves can pile up to real
problems and this is the first step and
y is like we need to record Queenie to
be questionable the main reason is well
black plays Bishop e7 we start with that
the main reason is that black will
definitely play Knight f6 castles rook
e8 those moves will definitely be honest
agenda and then the Queen on e2 is
really not well placed you don't want to
be in the ephah with the Queen where the
black rook is
so long-term you are forced to move the
Korean again and well you don't have a
great spot for this piece we would see
how it unfolds in the game he now um
took on c5 of course and well you cannot
Castle for instance after c4 yeah it
would be very embarrassing so right yet
the capture makes lots of sense caution
just played Knight f6 he's just focusing
on its development black shouldn't think
about moves like let's take my hive
trying to get the pawn back quickly you
are not going to ya lose it anyway
long-term just 90 f6 is perfectly okay
white has no way to protect this pawn
let's say he tries but should be three
in the long run he will not be able to
keep it let's say castles castles rook
e8 and now we are threatening Bishop
takes e5 using this opposition of rook
and queen yeah here white is already
forced to move the Queen again which
does not really help him like back to d1
it's a it's just not very good to put
the Queen in the e-file yeah he went h3
and this is again a bit questionable and
he was probably afraid of Bishop g4 but
I'm not sure that you can afford this
luxury spending yet another move for ya
without developing and it also implies a
weakening of the Kings side which at the
moment does not look very relevant but
ya see what happens
black castles white castles and now
black got the pawn back on c5 you think
he took two moves to take on c5 so you
might argue that Queen e2 yeah it's a
move that does not really help much but
and it does not help much but like also
has lost a move but the main point is
that there was c3 was played a normal
move to control them the square here
rook e8 and now we see the big problem
where should the Queen go the relatively
best Square is really deep
the one is a better square than c2
because it keeps mom
it keeps also this night protected which
is useful
they haven't know what it's going to
play a hit queen back to d1 he went
Queen c2 and the Queen really does not
belong on c2 in this structure you
wanted yeah ideally back on d1 and want
to try to slowly get some sort of
control over D for the square in front
of the isolated pawn
however we are already talking about a
position where white is in deep trouble
Coronel now played a very strong very
strong and this is a move that really
should be yeah remembered in a way
because it can come up time and time
again in in very similar situation
corner course are not played the move
Queen to d6 what's the point of the move
they had the big point is that Wyatt
with h3 has weakened his King side black
is actually threatening something here
he is threatening the absolutely
shattering move Bishop takes h3 of
course only possible because white has
played the moves h3 if we look at a move
like rook t1 that simply ignores all of
that black really just smashes here and
wins immediately the point is that this
big check is coming assisted by this
this great Bishop now white of course
will use very quickly my king news and
and he's going going down in flames
Bishop f3 is a big threat and it's
really not easy to do something against
it what exactly are you going to do this
is also reasonable by the way why the
Queen relatively speaking would be
better on d1 because it keeps f3
protected at least yeah tat I'm played
the most night be d2 this makes sense
because it covers f3 so the immediate
Bishop takes h3
it's not not really on anymore it was
interesting it's not a bad move and in
fact to take on h3 but black now already
has a better way a better way to play
question I just went move Queen to g3
yeah you can go there it is assisted by
the bishop and now black again threatens
Bishop takes h3 and here white really
has no response to that it's really
really a really funny if he goes let's
say King edge want to start to start
with the move
yeah then black has a simple choice you
just take it yeah this is hanging and
white really has no move here now Bishop
h3 is now an additional threat and after
something like that we just retreat and
continue from here we have two we have
one upon and we have an overwhelming
King side attack also 94 is coming
terrible for white
yeah if King h1 is not not helping at
all what else is there if he goes on
here then after Bishop takes h3 it's
already a false checkmate Quinjet takes
g2 cannot be prevented if white tries to
cover this we're just going to take the
defender and white will be mated in very
short order now in the game he played
Bishop f5 there's really no defense
anymore this is of course designed to
prevent black from taking on h3 but it
allows a second attacking motif rookie
to Bishop takes f2 is the main point now
and white has absolutely no cover for
that he went 94 but black can simply
take because the Queen is not really
hanging I mean it is hanging but black
of course gets the Queen back with check
and this huge chunks of material up
the loop here on a1 after 94 night xt
for cd4 actually sorry after Knight
takes d4 Tata actually resigned but it
will continue like that and f2 is
collapsing white has no way to cover the
pawn so a very very quick distraction
here of the exchange French it shows
that even in those kind of lame
innocent-looking openings you can
sometimes get really quick wins and if
you play em really yeah pretty
aggressively and and very purposefully
trying to really punish what the other
side is doing wrong here white has made
a couple of small things small mistakes
then powered up to this catastrophe yeah
Bishop d3 Queen e2 mm m h304ee72 tougher
difficult now for y2 to stay in the game
this Queen g3 or Bishop takes h3 idea is
really really tough to counter know that
I think of it what what about King h1 by
the way just just for just for starters
what does black do now now you will play
94 I guess and this is also not looking
very good if we consider that Bishop f5
is coming and white has a hard time to
develop you cannot play 92 as f2 hangs
how do you actually develop let's say 93
I just want to show really how it could
have unfolded note that black is
perfectly developed not b5 and Queen
here in order to threaten those kind of
checks you know for example Jack
something like that might happen yeah
it's a good way to see how smooth to
battle
to Bethel Bishop d3 in them in the
exchange French note that Knight f3 c5
is by far not as good as white here has
the opportunity to give the check on
July Finn one move and here white gets
cancelled quickly and has does not have
this misplaced Bishop on d3 this is in
fact quite an argument for not playing
c5 this is some a big difference to the
bishop on on d3 yeah I hope you enjoyed
this game and maybe you got a nice
weapon out of this for combating the
French exchange thanks for watching